more thanos backstory a Captain Marvel
scene and multiple epic trailer shots
are just some of the things that got the
chopped from the final version of
Avengers infinity war epic I may be
lovers it's Jan here and it's time to
talk to Lita scenes and rejected
concepts that never made it into the
magnificently ambitious third Avengers
movie I've got an infinity war giveaway
running for all my subscribers so hit
the bell I'll have more details later
and obviously spoilers ahead for the
movie so take care if you haven't seen
it yet in Avengers infinity war the
grand villain Thanos takes center stage
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe and boy
does he make an impression
prior to this we just had brief scenes
of the Mad Tyson in both Avengers post
credits and short scenes with him in
guardians of the galaxy so it's a bit of
a shame some moments with the big purple
guy teased and the trailers didn't make
it into the final film for instance
although ebony more told the black order
to let Thanos have his fun smashing the
Hulk on the Asgardian ship this next
epic line from Thanos didn't make it
into the movie fun isn't something one
considers from balancing the universe
but this does put a smile on my face
and this shot of Thanos coming in with
an almighty punch during the Tyson
fights was also cut plus there was a
more extensive backstory for the very
big bad which we didn't get to see
because after considering it the
Rousseau's felt it wasn't necessary for
the movie some fans might have liked to
touch more background about Thanos's
earlier life or young years on Titan
Thanos did mention in the movie that he
was labeled a madman for his suggestion
about fixing the planet's resources
problem but we didn't get to learn about
for example how he was also ostracized
for being like the Quasimodo of his time
as Josh Brolin called him which might
have made the audience feel free more
obviously more backstory from the
villain would have meant a longer run
time though and Marvel does also have a
non canon book called Thanos Titan
consumed which will reveal more of his
origins before the events of infinity
war the impressive shot of Thor standing
tall after the creation of Stormbreaker
with lightning crackling around him
while gruesome rocket lock-on was also
chopped from the final film and this
shot in it earlier of the Asgardian God
wearing his red cape didn't make it in
either I suspect both these moments came
just before Thor Youth storm breakers
Bifrost powers for his grand entrance in
Wakanda although both those Lightning
and Cape shots are really cool I can
understand why they were cut as Thor's
arrival in what Canada becomes even more
breathtaking when we go from having seen
him about to be revived with his new
weapon and then next time we see him
he's slamming down Stormbreaker taking
out the outriders that are overwhelming
our heroes and that line of thought
preparing himself to restart the forges
on new devaglia
also hit the cutting room floor and
there are many scenes that were chopped
out of the Wakanda parts of the film as
well first of all there was this scene
of Bruce Banner standing next to the
Hulkbuster arm talking to what looks
like Black Widow there I wonder if this
might have been a little private moment
between them which addressed the PIRs
previous relationship banner and
Romanoff was separated after the Hulk
ended up on the quinjets at the end of
age of Ultron and she doesn't see him
again until team cap visits the New
Avengers facility where they have an
awkward little reunion in this film then
there was also a shock curse of Black
Widow Bruce Banner and war machine
watching the alien in vain
descend on were candor and this moment
with cap trying out his new shield into
Charla's palace was also cut from the
final movie let's go
another Captain America and Black
Panther deleted moment was this shot of
the pair on the wakandan craft as a zoom
out to face the outriders we also never
saw this very cool shot of Hulk Buster
jumping and landing instead there was a
different shot in the movie where he
jumps into the battlefield which is
filled without riders thus of course
there was also that amusing moment when
Hulk Buster runs and falls flat on his
face and perhaps some think many of us
were hoping to see was that epic shot of
cap leading the charge with all the
heroes around him plus the work and an
army and a hulked out banner other than
on the Asgardian ship we never actually
saw the Hulk do battle because banner
failing to coax out the Jade giant was
an interesting running theme in the
movie so this scene here was presumably
edited or shot solely for marketing
purposes so if you wanted to see the
Hulk burst out of Hulk Buster like this
toy you were out of luck now we do get a
nice reunion between Steve and Bucky and
Wakanda but it looks like there were
other Bucky scenes we didn't get to see
according to infinity war press set
visits after Steven Bucky hug Bucky says
so little green men huh to which black
widow replies not little and not green
and then there was a bit of Falcon and
Bucky into play cut from the movie which
would have shown Sam Wilson Joe Kelly
asking Bucky are you gonna snap and kill
someone if they say baloney sandwich
which is a comical callback to the
activation codes used to trigger the
Winter Soldier something we last saw in
Civil War also drink set visits the
Russo brothers were asked who had the
best costume in infinity war and they
replied Captain Marvel adding Captain
Marvel on set is that fishel if it's not
official it's official now as I
mentioned in my full breakdown at the
movies post credits scene we did of
course get a tease for Captain Marvel
via Nick Fury's pager but it sounds like
originally she was going to be part of
the film in some way maybe making an
actual appearance in the post credits
scene which perhaps might have ended on
a shot of brie Larson receiving Fury's
message if you go back and re-watch the
trailers from finiti war it's clear the
a lot of the shots and the movie were
changed in the marketing material to
avoid revealing spoilers
we know that Thanos had five Infinity
stones when he finally arrived in
Wakanda
but when cap went up against him only
two were in the trailer
other modified shots include this
awesome shot of Spidey swinging through
Titan which in the final movie turned
out to be a shot of Spidey with his iron
spider legs plus he was also carrying
mantis in this New York scene in the
movie Tony's new nanotech Iron Man suit
was already wrapping itself around him
but in the trailer we just see Tony with
his normal clothes and in the first
trailer we saw an unarmed cap fighting
out riders whereas in the final movie he
had his new shields in these shots these
edits to the marketing material are
similar to how Thor's missing eye was
handled in the trailers for Thor
Ragnarok interestingly another way the
Russos tried to stop the plot leaking
out was that they actually gave fake
scripts to a lot of the actors and it's
possible that some of them didn't even
know they were going to fade away at the
end of the film when they were shooting
those scenes as a deleted scenes an
alternate takes which the Russos have
said may well show up on the blu-ray
came about because of the large amount
of improv on set the directors were
bringing it together characters from
movies with very distinct tones and
often those characters are meeting each
other for the first time and so the
filmmakers spent extra time making sure
they got the chemistry right in those
scenes allowing the actors to improvise
for several takes after doing an initial
couple of takes from the script for
example Thor's never heard of or met the
Guardians when he lands on their ship
right let's get it on pump this dude
still alive he is not a dude
Nura dude this this is a man my handsome
muscular man it's like as muscles are
made of cotati metal fibers stop
massaging his muscles and given the
humor we saw play out in that scene I
can imagine there's some very funny
alternate or extended takes it was
initially reported that the running time
for Avengers infinity war was going to
be a hundred and fifty six minutes but
then a few weeks later it was officially
announced that the final run time was
one hundred and forty nine minutes seven
minutes less bringing in the movie to
just under two and a half hours it seems
like this could be a possible
explanation for where some of these
missing scenes went as the filmmakers
may have been editing outfits they felt
for what the movies pasted down--
another thing that never made it into
the movie from the early drafts was an
idea the screenwriters came up with for
a giant snake in an interview with
Entertainment Tonight co-writer
Christopher Markus said we were sort of
running on empty and we were like snake
big snake let's try a big snake and then
everyone went insane I imagine the
writers might have been thinking of a
character like the Asgardian Midgard
serpent from the comics which was hinted
out briefly in Thor Ragnarok that's one
time we were children he he transformed
himself into a snake and he knows that I
love snakes so I went to pick up the
snake to admire it and he transformed
back into himself and he was like yeah
it's me and he stabbed me we were eight
by the time the enormous snake didn't
make it into the final draft though and
it's probably from the best given how
packed infinity war was already also
depending on how its scenes played out
in the creatures design it might have
felt to visually similar to the
Leviathans from the first Avengers now
do you wish any of these deleted scenes
had been included in the movie and what
do you think about fake scenes being
shot let me know in the comments below
and make sure you're subscribed for a
chance to win a very cool infinity war
Funko pop tap left to check out my deep
dive into the movies ending in Avengers
4 and tap right for the full playlist
with Easter eggs post
but it's break downs and cast interviews
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers